[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بابرز العناوين
موسكو تعلن احباطه هجوم غير مسبوق على
واشنطن تشكك بتقارير عن استخدام اسلحتها
بالهجوم
واشنطن تت
وعد وقف اطلاق النار بالسودان وجوتيرش
يكشف عن فرار 250 الف شخص من هناك
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل تحذر من تقدم ايران بتخصيب
اليورانيوم وتتوعد باجراءات لردعها
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
تواصلوا ازمه سقف الدين بالولايات المتحده
الجمهوريون يشترطون خفضا بالنفقات
وتحذيرات من نفاذ الاموال
اهلا بكم نبدا من تطورات الهجوم على مناطق
روسيا حدوديه اذ اعلن حاكم مقاطعه الروسيه
الغاء نظام مكافحه الارهاب في المقاطعه
بعد يوم من فرضه على خلفيه تسلل مجموعه
تخريبيه اوكرانيه على حد وصف المسؤول
الروسي كما اكد حاكم بلوغرود اجلاء نحو
100 شخص من بلدتي جلوتوف وكيزونوك في
المقاطعه فيما اعلنت السلطات مقتل شخص
واصابه ثلاثه عشر جرى الهجوم
الخارجيه الامريكيه شككت بتقارير تحدثت عن
احتماليه استخدام اسلحه امريكيه في هجوم
بيلوجرود واكدت رفضها شن ضربات داخل روسيا
اما نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه غانمار
فقد اعتبرت الوضع في المقاطعه هو ازمه
داخليه روسيه واكدت ان بلادها لا تخوض
حروبا على اراضي اجنبيه
بين هذه الصور وهذه تحول جديد في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتقاذف بالاتهامات بين
كييف وموسكو اتهامات بحقيقه واحده حتى
اللحظه حقيقه تقول ان المعركه عبرت الحدود
الاوكرانيه
بالقرود تحت النار
بعمق ثمانيه كيلو مترات داخل الاراضي
الروسيه تتعرض مدينه بيلجرود لهجمات قيل
انها اوكرانيه الهجوم وفقا للكرملين بدا
بطائرات مسيره تبعه اقتحام قوه عسكريه
قالت انهم مجموعه من المخربين امر دفع
السلطات لاجلاء المدنيين من تسع قرى
حدوديه واعلان نظام مكافحه الارهاب
في اول تعليق روسي على التطورات الجديده
اتهم الكرملين كييف بالوقوف وراء الهجوم
بهدف تحويل الانتباه عن باخموت اتهام
رفضته كييف ونفت علاقتها بالهجوم وفقا
للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه فان الهجوم نفذته
مجموعتان روسيتان معارضتان الاولى تسمى
فيلق حريه روسيا وثانيه فيلق المتطوعين
الروس وكلا المجموعتين تتالفان من مواطنين
روس اذ اعلنت احدى المجموعتين تحرير بلده
كوزينك الحدوديه مع ان الهجوم ليس الاول
على الاراضي الروسيه منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وكان قد سبقه هجوم على الكرمله
نفسه الا انه الاول الاقتحام وتوغل عسكري
داخل روسيا هجوم قد يفتح ابوابا جديده من
الحرب وتطوراتها
روسيا تتمكن من صد ما وصفته باخطر توغل في
اراضيها منذ بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا وتعلن
اخراج المجموعات المسلحه من روسيا نتحدث
هنا عن مقاطعه
الروسيه الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا اليها دخلت
مجموعه مسلحه من اوكرانيا واصابت نقاط
تفتيش على الحدود بنيران الدبابات وايضا
المسيرات ودخلت الى عمق المقاطعه ما يسمى
بفيلق حريه روسيا اعلن عبر صفحات على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مسؤوليته عن
الهجوم وسيطرته على قرى كوزينكا
كما تم الابلاغ عن وقوع قتال في درونوفكا
كما نشاهد هناك ايضا ما لم تعلق عليه
السلطات الروسيه والتي اكتفت بتوجيه
الاتهامات لاوكرانيا الهجوم يعيد للواجهه
تصريحات لقائد مجموعه فاجنر الذي قال ان
اوكرانيا تحضر لهجوم على مقاطعات حدوديه
وتحديدا على بيلوجرود وبرياسك واتهم
السلطات بعدم القدره على حمايه الحدود
الروسيه ايضا التخطيط لهذه الهجمات ليس
بالجديد فوفقا لتسريبات البانتاجون التي
نشرتها واشنطن بوست في اجتماع عقد اواخر
يناير اقترح الرئيس الاوكراني احتلال مدن
حدودي روسيه لاعطائك ولقد ضغط في اي
محادثات قادمه مع موسكو الوثائق ذكرت ان
اوكرانيا خططت لتنظيم عمليات تسلل تسلل
للمقاتلين هم متطوعين الى مقاطعه بريانسك
وكورسك للسيطره على مدن روسيه واعلان
جمهوريات مستقله فيها طبعا على غرار مناطق
شرق اوكرانيا واشارت الوثائق ايضا الى ان
اوكرانيا تخطط لتشكيل مكون عسكري اكبر
يعتمد على متطوعين لاحداث وفتح جبهه حرب
اهليه في روسيا
وفي ملف الدعم الغربي لكياف اكد الامين
العام لحلف الناتو يانس ضروره زياده الدول
الاعضاء لانتاجها العسكريه لامداد
اوكرانيا باسلحه والذخيره وقال ستولتنبرغ
في تصريحات صحفيه ان تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على استخدام مقاتلات اف 16 لا
يجعل من الحلف طرفا في هذا الصراع وشدد
الامين العام لحلف الناتو على ان اوكرانيا
لديها الحق في الدفاع عن النفس مشيرا الى
ان الحلف يساعدها على تمسك بهذا الحق
[موسيقى]
علينا ان نتذكر ان هذه حرب عدوانيه
اوكرانيا لديها حق الدفاع عن نفسها انهم
يدافعون عن انفسهم ومساله الدفاع عن النفس
هي حق منصوص عليه في ميثاق الامم المتحده
ونحن نساعد اوكرانيا على التمسك بهذا الحق
وانه من حقنا مساعدتهم على حمايه قانون
الامم المتحده والقانون الدولي ضد الحرب
العدوانيه وهذا لا يجعل حلف النيتو حلفائه
طرفات الصراع لكننا ندعم اوكرانيا للدفاع
عن نفسها ضد هذه الحرب العدوانيه من قبل
الرئيس بوتين
الى ذلك قال الممثل السامي للاتحاد
الاوروبي للشؤون الخارجيه والسياسيه
الامنيه ان هدف الاتحاد هو توفير مليون
قذيفه مدفعيه لاوكرانيا عبر مقاربه ثلاثيه
يا بنت كما تعلمون في العشرين من مارس
قررنا تخصيص ملياري يورو لتزويد الذخيره
للمدفعيه الاوكرانيه
الهدف هو توفير مليون قذيفه مدفعيه خلال
الاثني عشر شهرا القادمه وسيكون نهجا
ثلاثيا المسارات اولا سنطلب من الدول
الاعضاء توفير الذخيره من مخزونها حتى لا
ننتظر انتاج المزيد من الذخائر لكننا
سنستفيد من الذخيره الموجوده
واحدث الارقام افضل بكثير مما كان لدينا
قبل عشره ايام فقط لانني استطيع ان اعلن
اليوم انه بفضل هذا المسار قدمت الدول
الاعضاء 220 الف ذخيره مدفعيه من عيارات
مختلفه وتم توفير 1300 صاروخ
وانضم الينا او تنضم الينا منك يا فلادا
الخبيره الاستراتيجيه في الامن والدفاع
اهلا بك سيده لادا يعني عمليه عسكريه
تخريبيه على مدينه بيلوجرود
واوكرانيا وراءها هكذا تقول روسيا ما الرد
الاوكراني وكيف يعني يدافعون عن نفسهم
الاوكران
تدافع عن نفسها قدر الامكان
بكل الدعم الضروري والمطلوب ما تقوله
روسيا فيما يخص دعائاتها
الخاصه بعمليه بالتاكيد روسيا ستقول ان
اوكرانيا هيلتي قام في هذه العمليه ولكن
من المهم ان ندرك ان هنالك اشخاص في روسيا
ممن لا يرغبون بالعيش تحت نظام
فهذا تطور ايجابي جدا ويفتحون نافذه
لخلق بوابه محتمله ليس فقط في بالجراد بل
ربما حتى بوابه امنيه الى جانب الحدود
الروسيه وصولا الى البحر الاسود
ابقي معنا سيده لادا سنذهب لنشاهد هذا
الفيديو للهجوم على مقاطعه بيل قرود
الحدوديه
من جديد سيده لادا شاهدنا هذا الفيديو
للفيلق هو تحت مسمى حريه روسيا
كيف يمكن تبرير انه يعني على ثيابه هنالك
العلم الاوكراني ولماذا تستبعدين ان تكون
اوكرانيا وراء هذا الهجوم على
استراتيجيه وهي مثاليه للاستهداف هي نقطه
لتدريب القوات الروسيه بها شبكات مواصلات
قريبه من خاركاف بشكل كبير ويعني مهمه
لتعزيز منظومه الامداد
عكس
واعتقد بان واحده من اهم الاسئله
ليس هو ان كان اوكرانيين
في العام الماضي بان الروس
تعلم كيف يرتدون البازات الاوكرانيه عندما
يقومون العملياتي اباده ضد الاوكرانيين
ولكن من ناحيه الاستراتيجيه وخاصه لخبرائي
للدفاع والامن فالسؤال هو لماذا
روسيا لا تحكم او تدافع عن حدودها الرسميه
مع اوكرانيا لو كان
الامر كذلك لما
تمكن هذا الفيلق من القيام بهذه العمليه
ان هيكي عن اتهام اوكرانيا فهذا موقف
استراتيجي مثير اي يجب التركيز عليه وهو
بلدي تقوم به روسيا ان لم تكن تحمي حدودها
الشرعيه
سيده لدى يعني هل هناك تخوف اوكراني من رد
فعل روسي خاصه والان هناك تحذيرات كبيره
روسيه لاوكرانيا من وصول 16
يحكم شكل الاستبدادي ويقوم بعمليه بادا
ويحكم دوله بشكل شرعي
الخبيرات والاستراتيجيه في الامن والدفاع
[موسيقى]
جويه جديده تظهر مدينه باخموت او ما تبقى
منها بعد اعلان روسيا السيطره عليها فكره
معارك لاكثر من ثمانيه اشهر تابعونا بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهيد اكد تقرير للاستخبارات
الالمانيه ان القدرات العسكريه الروسيه لا
تزال قادره علشان حروب طويله الامد رغم
الحرب الدائره مؤكدا اللدا الى على ضعف
بوتين بعد 15 شهرا من القتال
شهاده المانيه تقييم استخبارتي
اشاد بقوه بوتين ونظامه وان نفسه لا يزال
طويلا
رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات يقول لا مؤشرات على
ضعف نظام بوتين ولا حتى تصدعات ملحوظه
بعد 15 شهرا على الحرب روسيا قادره علشان
حرب طويله
تقييم الماني سببه اعتماد روسيا على
التجنيد وايضا التسلح والذخيرات
تصريحات تزامنت مع تصدي روسيا لعمليات
اوكرانيه على الحدود
عمليات نفتها كييف سابقا
كشفت صور جويه تم التقاطها لمدينه باخموت
حجم الدمار الذي طال المدينه التي شهدت
معارك داريا خلال اشهر
[موسيقى]
مددت روسيا اعتقال الصحفي الامريكي ايفان
جيرسكوفيتش المتهم بالتجسس لمده ثلاثه
اشهر بطلب من جهاز الامن الفيدرالي وفي
هذا الاطار طالب الناطق باسم مجلس الامن
القومي جون كاريبي بالافراج عن المراسل
الامريكيه فورا مؤكدا ان جريشكوفيتش لا
يجب اعتقاله ولا تمديد سجنه مشددا على
ضروره وصول القنصليه الامريكيه الى
الصحفيه
حول مساله تصدير الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود
اكد مسؤول اوكراني بان العمل بميناء
بيفداني
متوقف لان روسيا لا تسمح بدخول السفن اليه
مما ادى لخروج الميناء من اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه من جهازها اعربت الامم
المتحده عن قلقها من عدم استقبال الميناء
القريب من اوديسا على البحر الاسود اي
السفن منذ الثاني مما يو بموجب الاتفاق
وقال يوري فاسكوف نائب وزير البنيه
التحتيه الاوكراني في بيان له ان روسيا
وجدت طريقه فعاله للحد بصوره كبيره من
صادرات الحبوب الاوكرانيه وذلك من خلال
استبعادها لهذا الميناء الذي يستقبل سفنا
بحمولات كبيره
قال الامين العام للامم المتحده ان مئات
المدنيين قتلوا من دندلاع الحرب في
السودان قبل سته اسابيع بينهم افراد من
الامم المتحده وبين غوتيرش ان عدد الفري
من السودان بلغ 250 الف شخص مشيرا الى ان
المستشفيات احتلت وهجمت فيما تعرضت مخازن
الاغاثه للنهب على مستوى هائل كما قال ان
اسعار السلع ارتفعت بمقدار اربعه اضعاف
هذا وحذرت اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
من خطر وقوع كارثه تهدد سلامه اللاجئين
السودانيين في تشاد مع اقتراب موسم
الامطار في اواخر شهر يونيو القادم
بوتيره عاليه جدا
يتدفقون الى تشاد هذا حال اللاجئين
السودانيين الفارين غربا اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر رصدته هروب المدنيين
60 الى 90 الف لاجئ دخلوا تشاد
80% منهم نساء واطفال
يتكدسون في مخيم مؤقت لا مناطق اكثر امانا
تستوعب اعدادهم
المطر ضيف ثقيل اخر يهددهم
فالمناطق الحدوديه تشهد سيولا غزيره
وديان قد تعيق وصول المساعدات المنتظره
وتنذر معها بكارثه انسانيه اكبر
[موسيقى]
فلت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان لديها ادوات
للتعامل مع انتهاك وقف النار بالسودان ولن
تتردد باستخدامها وقد هدد وزير الخارج
الامريكيه
بمحاسبه المنتهكين وفرض عقوبات عليهم
محملا الجيش ودعم السريع مسؤوليه تطبيق
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في البلاد
اذا انتهك وقف اطلاق النار سنعرف وسنحاسب
المخالفين من خلال عقوبات نفرضها ووسائل
اخرى متاحه لنا لقد ظللنا الصعوبات
للتواصل الى وقف اطلاق النار هذا لكن
مسؤوليه تنفيذه تقع على عاتق القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع ان
الحل الدائم للصراع يتطلب اكثر من ذلك
بكثير اريد ان اوضح ان المدنيين في
السودان يجب ان يكونوا من يحددون مسار
السودان للمضي قدما
مجلس الوزراء السعودي رحب من جهته بتوقيع
طرفي النزاعب السودان على اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار قصير الامد كما اعرب مجلس الوزراء
السعودي برئاسه الملك سلمان عن امله في ان
تركز المحادثات السودانيه على وقف دائم
للاعمال العدائيه وتفعيل العمليه السياسيه
والان المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان يامل في ان تؤدي او يؤدي هذا
الهدوء لوقف دائم لاطلاق النار وحول هذا
الموضوع موضوع الانساني تحديدا ينضم الينا
من سلفانيا عبر سكايب هاجر سيد احمد عضو
الشبكه السودانيه لحقوق الانسان اهلا بك
معنا السيده هاجر يعني كيف تسير العمليات
الانسانيه وايضا ارسال المساعدات وكم سهلت
هذه الهدنه هدله هدنه وقف اطلاق النار
لسبعه ايام
العمليات الاغاثيه
يا مرحب وشكرا للتغطيه اولا احب ان اترحم
على ارواح الشهداء في الوضع الوقت الحالي
لا نرى اي تغيير الهدنه
بدت
الامس الاثنين
مازال هنالك اصوات من الضرب مع ذلك ما زال
هنالك
تعدي من الطرفان من الدعم السريع الجنجويد
ومن القوات الجيش السوداني عدد كبير
مصاب وعدد
لعشرين من القتلى من الامس لليوم فالوضع
الانساني كارثي كما ذكرت في تقريرك
المسبق وعدد اللاجئين الان يفوق
في المنطقه التشاد وكما ذكرتي الشهر
القادم في يونيو حيكون في وضع انساني اسوا
بحلول الامطار هنالك عقارب و
من العقارب والثعابين في الحدود مع تشاد
اكثر من 113 الف لاجئ موجودون الان بمصر
وداخل السودان المستشفيات ضربت معظم
المستشفيات خارج الخدمه بضرب مباشر سواء
كان جوي او بتعدي افراد جنجويد او دعم
السريع على الكوادر الصحيه وعلى المواطنين
كثير من المواطنين لم يستطيعوا دفن يعني
افراد اسره تشكل النظر او ازر او وضع
كارثي اخر
بعد حلول الامطار لان تلك جتامين لم تتم
مواراتها بالشكل السليم
وسنواجه كارثه اخرى نعم بما يخص ما قالته
الامم المتحده عن انه 90 الف شخص لجاوا من
السودان الى تشاد عبر الحدود هربا طبعا من
المعارك ما هي ابرز الملاحظات حول هؤلاء
حول اوضاعهم في تلك المنطقه الحدوديه
الاوضاع سيئه جدا لانه هنالك
ما يقل عن خمس خمس معسكرات موجوده اصلا في
المنطقه
وقاموا بترحيل جزء بسيط جدا من اللاجئين
الموجودين في الحدود
للمعسرات بتحاول الحكومه وبتحاول حاول
الصليب الاحمر والامم المتحده بترحيل جزء
كبير قبل يونيو او قبل بدء الامطار لان
الوضع يعني كارثي ما في مواد غذائيه
صعوبه ايصال المواد الطبيه في الحدود او
في حدود مصر او في داخل السودان حتى
الهدنه الان لم نرى اي
فائده او استفاده منها الى الان لان عدد
كبير جدا من المواطنين الذين يحتاجون الى
ادويه الكلى زارعون كلى او يحتاجون لغسيل
كلى كمثال بعضهم يحتاجون الى ادويه
الانسولين
للعلاج السكري نعم مع انه الهدنه الجديده
السيده هاجر اشترطت فتح مسارات امنه
للبعثات والمساعدات الانسانيه على كل
الاحوال نشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات
السيده هاجر سيد احمد عضو الشبكه
السودانيه لحقوق الانسان
اثرت الحرب الدائره حتى الان في السودان
على قطاع عريض من الحرفيين والعمال في شرق
دارفورد اذ يعاني الالاف من ضيق العيش
وصعوبه الحصول على الطعام مما جعل بعض
الخيرين يقومون بمبادرات لاطعام الشرائح
الضعيفه الصحه في صالح ابو علامه رصد
الوضع في دارفور
مع كل يوم جديد تدخله الحرب المستمره في
السودان بين الجيش والدعم السريع تهدد
المجاعه قطاعا واسعا من المجتمع السوداني
فقد مضى على الحرفيين وعمال البناء في
الضعين غربيه السودان اكثر من شهر بدون
عمل وما زالت مخاوفهم مستمره من اطاله امد
الصراع نحن في نقابه البنين تاثر الهرفين
في كل المجالات في كل الهرف في هذه الحرب
هذه الهربه للعين ولا نسال الله سبحانه
وتعالى ان يقف هذه اللحم ويحقن الدماء من
من هذه المصيبه الورطه الذي وضعنا في ما
يفوق الخمسه مئات عامل بشرق دارفور اليوم
خرج دائره الانتاج من بينهم ابو القاسم
صالح علي الذي ياتي الى هذا المكان يوميا
يتبادل الاخبار مع رفغائه املين في وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار في السودان لتعود
الامور الى ما كانت عليه
الناس يعني تنظر ليله بان الرحمه
ساعد الناس
الناس دي مضرره يعني عماله واقف ما شغاله
الواحد لا يملك قوتيمه
يعني الوجبه لوحدي له صعبه والله الهدنه
هي كويسه يعني اذا تحققت ونتمنى تكون
دايمه
لانه الحرب عصر مع المواطن يعني
مع الاوضاع القاسيه يقوم الحرفيون يوميا
باعداد وجبه الافطار بدعم من الخيرين
يتشارك فيها الجميع علها تسد رمقهم وتخفف
عنهم صعوبه الايام
ووطئت الحاجه ونحن لما شفنا بانه الناس دي
بتجي من الصباح لغايه المساء ما بتلقى حق
الفطور ما بتلقى حق الشاي ما بتلقى يعني
اي شيء يهو بدينا بالبليله دي كوجبه
وجبه لغايه الساعه 11 12
ان شاء الله بتناولها كذا
ومستغرينا عليها كده في ظل الحرب التي
يعيشها السودان تزداد
والا مجتمع سوءا لا سيما البطاله وانعدام
الامن والغذاء واقع قد لا ينتهي الا
باسكات صوت البندقيه
[موسيقى]
يمحي اوكرانيا من التاريخ تابعونا بعض
اهلا بكم من جديد حضر رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي من تقدم ايران في تخصيب
اليورانيوم اكثر من اي وقت مضى مشددا على
ان هذا التقدم السلبي قد يؤدي الى اتخاذ
اجراءات محتمله قريبا على حد وصفه
ايران بقرين تقدمت ايران في برنامجها
النووي في السنوات الاخيره في تخصيب
اليورانيوم اكثر من اي وقت مضى نحن نراقب
عن كثب ايضا المجالات المتعلقه بالتطوير
النووي وبدون الخوض في التفاصيل ايضا بسبب
الوقت ساقول ان هناك تطورات سلبيه محتمله
في الافق ويمكن ان تؤدي الى اتخاذ اجراءات
وهذا امر مهم للغايه
[موسيقى]
في مقابله مع قناه تي ار سي التركيه اكد
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ان انقره تعمل على
اعداد خطه لعوده اللاجئين السوريين الى
بلادهم في الوقت القريب وسط اتهامات بتغير
لهجه اردوغان في مخاطبه اللاجئين
مع احتدام السباق الرئاسي في الانتخابات
التركيه تبرز ورقه اللاجئين كملف يلوح به
المتنافسان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يبدو وكانه يتراجع عن مواقفه حول اللاجئين
وبدا في الحديث بلغه تبدو اكثر صرامه
اردوغان وفي احدى المقابلات اكد انه وضع
خطه لاعاده اللاجئين السوريين الى ديارهم
واوضح انه قد تم بالفعل ارجاع 450 الفا
خلال الفتره الماضيه
تصريحات اردوغان تتناغم مع اقوال وزير
خارجيته حول الاعداد للقاءات قد تجري بين
الرئيس التركي ونظريه الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين والسوري بشار الاسد لمناقشه عوده
اللاجئين الى مناطق سيطره الحكومه السوريه
لكن اردوغان وبحسب اتهامات طالت مواقفه
كان يظهر كمدافع عن اللاجئين ويطمئنهم في
وقت كان يعقد صفقات من اجل التخلص من
عبئهم
ومع اقتراب الجوله الثانيه يخطط اردوغان
ماليا لمسالتهم كي لا يتركهم ورقه قويه
بيد المعارضه التي جعلتهم احدى اهم
الاوراق التي تروجها لتنال كرسي الرئاسه
خاصه وان منافسه كمال كليتش دار اوغلو
اعلن انه ينوي فعليا توديعهم عاجلا وليس
اجلا بخطه اقصاها سنتان ترتفع حده الخطاب
القومي في تركيا مع اقتراب ساعه الحسم
ويبقى اللاجئون الورقه التي تتجاذبها
الاطراف كافه في سبيل الحصول على اصوات
المصرين على رحيلهم من تركيا
جرعه من الامل تلقاها الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان قبل جوله الاعاده في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه التي تعقد
يوم الاحد المقبل 5% حصل عليها صاحب
المركز الثالث في الجوله الاولى سنان
اوغان دعا مؤيديه ان يضعوها في الصناديق
دعم لاردوغان بهذا وعلى الورق قد تبدو
الامور محسومه لصالح الرئيس اردوغان الا
ان محللين يرون مع ذلك فرصه لمرشح تحالف
الامه المعارض كمال كليتش دار اوغلو اكثر
من مليونين وثمانمائه الف صوت حصل عليها
سنان اوغان يتوقع خبراء ان تتوزع في
الجوله الثانيه بين المرشحين كليتش دور
اوغلو سيبقي على اعتماده على الصوت الكردي
الذي اعطاه يعني اعطاه عده اصوات في
الجوله
السابقه اذا لكن ما يشكل عائقا بالنسبه له
وجود
كتله اعطته مثل ما ذكرنا الصوت الكردي
كتله تاتي الى في المعارضه مع اختلافات
جذريه بين اطرافها التي اجتمعت بطبيعه
الحال على اهداف انتخابيه مرحليه على
الجانب الاخر الرئيس التركي سيكون مدعوما
بحصول ائتلافه على اغلبيه برلمانيه وايضا
ثبات الفئات الداعمه له كذلك حاول اردوغان
اغلاق الباب امام
انتقادات المعارضه باعترافه بعد الجوله
الاولى بقصور حزب العداله والتنميه وحاجته
الى النقد والتقويم وما بين هذه التوقعات
والامال والتحليلات يبقى الاتراك
والمتابعين بانتظار لحظه الحسم عندما تكشف
صناديق الاقتراع عما تحتوي حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من اسطنبول فائق بولوت
المحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد فائق يعني
هل برايك حسمت نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في جوله الاعاده للرئاسه في ظل عده عوامل
قد تكون لصالح اردوغان اول شيء دعم سنان
اوغان له 5%
النتائج الجيده التي حققها في البرلمان
بالجوله الاولى وايضا الخلافات على
الطاوله السداسيه ما رايك
يا سيدتي يعني الجوله الاولى شيء جوله
ثانيه اعاده الجوله الشئ الثاني اللي انا
يعني خلينا نقول المنافسه تبدا من الصفر
لا تبدا يعني لا تبنى على 90%
للسيد رجب طيبه
تبدا من صفر اولا الشيء الثاني يعني
استطلاع الاخير انا
اطلعت عليه عليها
اليوم
فتشير تشير هذه الاستطلاعات الميدانيه
تشير الى
60% من مؤيدي سنان اوغن سوف
يسوتون لصالح كمال
عشرين بالمئه سوف يقاطعون كل الطرفين ولكن
هذه يبقى ولكن هذه الاستطلاعات توقعت
الجوله الاولى ان يربحت لتشدار اوغلو ولم
يحصل ذلك
يعني انا اقول شيء يعني انا اقول شيء جديد
فيبقى في يد تبقى في السيد السينانوغان
تقريبا 20% يعني هو اذا مثل كاملا اذا
طبعا اقنع انصاره عشرين بالمئه من عشرين
بالمئه فسوف يصوت فقط عشرين بالمئه لصالح
السيد رجب وعن هذه النقطه الاساسيه النقطه
الثانيه يعني
طبعا خبراء في الشؤون الانتخابات يعني
يرون هناك فرصه جديده جدا امام السيد
انه اربعه من حزب الجيد يعني برئاسه
السيده نرى الاخشينير لم تسودوا في الجوله
الاولى لصالحه لكم بينما
السيده نرى الشابه على على
ترص الصفوف سوف تق وم
السداسيه سيد
فائق الجوله الاولى هل ذلك تخوين للسيده
ميرال
يعني مش قصه التقويم ذلك
الناس المؤيده لها لم تعطى
هي اعترفت فقط انه قسم من قسم من
مناصريها انصارها او ما يهديه لم يصوتوا
لصالح
لم يصوتوا لصالح كمال ولكن مره اخرى ركزت
يعني صرحت وركزت على انه سوف احاول كل ما
وسعي اقناع هذه الغير مسوتين لصالح
مره اخرى يصوت الصالح كما هذه نقطه مهمه
جدا هناك طبعا تقريبا مليون مليون صوت هو
غير مقبوله من ناحيه من ناحيه القواعد
الانتخابات بحيث يعني ختموا ختم خاتمات
خليك المختلطه غلط في على طبعا على
الصناديق وبالتالي
نعم اليوم كان هناك اجتماع بين كمال كليتش
دار
اوغل طالب بتوقيع الطاوله اعضاء الطاوله
السداسيه على النقطه او معاهده من اعضاء
الطاوله لاخراج اللاجئين قصرا اذا تطلب
الامر ذلك وتم تاجيل الاجتماع لاحقا هذا
التشردم بالمعارضه على الطاوله السداسيه
وهذا الخطاب القومي الذي يوصف الان بانه
فيه الكثير من الكراهيه والعدائيه ضد
اللاجئين السوريين كم سيكسب المعارضه من
اصوات او كم سيجعلها تخسر
يعني معارضه بالاساسيه تريد طبعا يعني
ارسال اللاجئين الى سوريا ولكن ليس في هذه
الطريقه لان يعني طريقه
يتبناها السيد هي الطريقه عنصريه جدا
كراهيه جدا يعني
ليس مقبوله لا الناحيه انسانيه ولا ناحيه
سياسيه يعني عنصريه مكروهه يعني بالنسبه
لكل يعني مكونات الطاوله السداسيه ولكن قد
يجدوا يعني صيغه معينه في فتره خلال يومين
او ثلاثه لا اكثر ولا اقل لان امامهم
ثلاثه ايام لا يقدر ولا خل على كل حال انا
سوف اعود اقول انه يعني
معيدين 60 60% من مؤيدين السنان اوغان سوف
يسوتنا بالتاكيد لصالح السيد كريستاله
تبقى هناك
محاوله محاوله اق
الاصوات الرماديه او متردده وهي طبعا عدد
داخل عدد ملايين اذا اذا
حاولوا اقناع تقريبا مليون ومليون ونص
من هذه الاصوات المتردده فبعتقد انه
بامكان بامكان يعني طبعا سياسه ليست
الاقوال القويه يعني نتحدث عنها بالصوره
حاسمه ولكن اذا اقنعوا مليون ومليون مليون
ونص شخص فبعتقد بالامكان ايضا
ان يفوز جوله ثانيه هذا يعني ما اقوله
بالاضافه الى اصوات يعني غير مقبوله من
ناحيه قواعد الانتخابات
هذه الاصوات ايضا كانت تصوت يعني لصالح
السيد كمال لاننا يعني
غلط او خا طئه بسبب ذلك يعني جمعنا على
بعض رقميا بالرقميا فانا بقول جوله سوف
تكون قد تكونوا يعني او احتمال ان تكون
محتملا ان تكون اللصالح كما الكوليسترول
غير ذلك لا استطيع ان اقول شيئا اخر شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد فائق قبلات المحلل السياسي
على هذا التحليل
[موسيقى]
تتواصل ازمه سقف الدين بالولايات المتحده
ياتي ذلك في مشترط الجمهوريون خفضا
بالنفقات التوصل الاتفاق وذلك وسط تحذيرات
من نفاد الاموال البيت الابيض بدوره
استبعد اللجوء الى الدستور لتجاوز الازمه
داخل اروقه البيت الابيض تجرى محادثات في
سباق مع الزمن وان قيل ان اصدارها ايجابيا
لكن ان فشلت في الوصول الى اتفاق ستعم
الفوضى ليس الاقتصاد الامريكي وحسب بل
العالميه ايضا فنزاع بين الحزبين
الامريكيين على مساله رفع سقف الدين عن
حده الاقصى البالغ واحدا وثلاثين تريليونا
و400 مليار دولار قد يؤدي للتخلف واشنطن
عن سداد ديونها امر يعني ان الحكومه لم
تستطيع اقتراض المال ودفع فواتيرها ويهدد
بفوضا في الاقتصاد العالمي وتدهور اسعار
ومعدلات الرهن العقاري العالميه وزيره
الخزانه كانت
حذرت الكونجرس بانه من المحتمل ان تنفذ
اموال الولايات المتحده وتتخلف عن سداد
فواتيرها في وقت مبكر من اول يونيو وبدون
رفع سقف الدين فان معاناه الاسر الامريكيه
ستكون شديده بيضا قال ان التخلف عن السداد
غير مطروح ووصف محادثاته مع رئيس مجلس
النواب كيفن مقاثي بانها بناء الاخير قال
انه يعتقد انه بالامكان التوصل للاتفاق ما
يعارض رفع سقف الدين يطالب الجمهوريون
بخفض في الميزانيه يزيد على اربعه
دولار امر سيؤدي الى الغاء العديد من
الاولويات التشريعيه لبايدن بينما يرفض
الديمقراطيون الخطوه ويعرضون بدلا من ذلك
الاستمرار في الانفاق دون تغيير
اسبوع صعب وثقيل سيعيشه الامريكيون حتى
بدايه يونيو تزيده ثقلا التحذيرات من فراغ
الخزينه وفوضى ما بعد الافلاس
[موسيقى]
يواجه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيوس
ضغوطا شديده لفتح تحقيق في ملابسات مخالفه
مروريه ارتكبتها وزيره الداخليه سويله
بريفيرمان العمل الماضي وخرقها للقوانين
الوزاريه عبر محاولتها تجنب عواقبها
القانونيه
في النجاه كوزيره للداخليه على وشك النفاذ
بعد تراكم اخطائها في الاشهر السبعه
الماضيه وزياده الضغوط من قبل النواب في
جلسه طارئه تطالب بفتح تحقيق اخلاقي في
انتهاكاتها اخرها معلومات كشفت عن
مطالبتها بمعامله تفضيليه للتهرب من
محاسبه مروريه مخالفه تكشف من خلالها عمق
الخلاف بينها وبين رئيس الوزراء ريشيسوناك
المحرج على ما يبدو اذ ان النزاهه
والمحاسبه كانتا من شعارات حملته
التنافسيه على منصب رئاسه الوزراء العام
الماضي والاحزاب المعارضه لا تبدو مستعده
لتجنيبه احراجا او محاسبته على مكتب وعوده
فهم ساكتين اعترفت وزيره داخليه سابقا من
خلقها القانون الوزري عند مشاركه معلومات
حساسه لذلك اسال اليوم كم عدد الفرص
المتاحه قبل تسريحها
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي تواجه فيها
وزيره الداخليه تحديا خلال مسيرتها
السياسيه اضطرت للاستقاله في اكتوبر
الماضي خلال عهد رئيسه الوزراء السابقه
بسبب انتهاك تقني هذه المره انتهاك مروري
لم يكن في الحسبه كنت اسرع وانا اسفه انني
كنت اسرع قبلت النقاط ودفعت الغرامه
ولكنني لم اسعى في اي وقت من الاوقات الى
تجنب العقوبات
لكن خلف الانتهاكات التي ارتكبتها
جعلتها محطه جدلا بين النواب وتصريحات
وضعتها تحت الاضواء احيانا على حساب سوناك
فموقفها المتشدد تجاه طالبين اللجوء اشعل
احتجاجات حقوقيين وجدوا قسوه في سياسه
ترحيلها للاجئين الى رواندا كما ان خطابها
في مؤتمر لحزب المحافظين الاسبوع الماضي
زاد من التكهنات بانها تتهيا لخوض منافسه
على قياده حزب المحافظين قبيل الانتخابات
العامه عده عوامل دفعت سونات للنظر في فتح
تحقيق اخلاقي في ملابسات مخالفه يرى في
تجاهلها مخاطره بسمعه مسيرته السياسيه
وتفريطا في الوعود التي يعول على نتائجها
في الفوز بالانتخابات المقبله من لندن
عروب عبد الحق العربيه
حصدت قناه العربيه على حصلت على 38 جائزه
من بينها خمس جوائز من الفئه الذهبيه من
جوائز تلي التي تعنى بتكريم التميز في
مجال التلفزيون والفيديو المزيد من
التفاصيل في التقرير التالي
زمان وثلاثون جائزه نصيب قناه العربيه من
جوائز تالي العالميه في نسختها الرابعه
والاربعين
الجائزه التي تنظم السنويا في الولايات
المتحده تقدم لارفع الانتاجات التلفزيونيه
وتقدم في فئات ثلاث
ذهبيه وفضيه مبرونسي
الجائزه تعد واحده من اهم الجوائز
المتخصصه في مجال تقييم محتوى الفيديو
والانتاج المرئي بمشاركه بئتي خبير من
مؤسسه اعلاميه وقنوات وشركات انتاج دوليه
ضمن الفئات التي ربحت جائزه التالي خمس
جوائز ذهبيه كانت من نصيبي ثلاثه برامج
وتغطيه على الصعيد البرامج برنامج على خطى
العرب ومهمه خاصه وعسكري تاريا اما على
الصعيد التغطيه فكانت من نصيب تغطيه
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه وكذلك تقرير
نفذ بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو بيض
جوائز التالي التي حازتها قناه العربيه
كانت ضمنها 20 جائزه فضيه وثلاثه عشره
جائزه من الفئه البرونزيه
ذهبت لعدد من برامج العربيه وتغطياتها
الخاصه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والوثائقيه
وبرامجها على مواقع التواصل والتصميم
الابداعي واستخدام الواقع المعزز
جوائز تيل العالميه الفئه الذهبيه البرامج
على خطى العرب مهمه خاصه
عسكري تاريا
التغطيات الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
تقرير بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو
بايدن
[موسيقى]
لا تصريح اليوم الحكومه سوفياتيه انشات
اوكرانيا الاشتراكيه وقبل ذلك لم تكن هناك
اوكرانيا تلك الكلمات للرئيس الروسي الذي
استعرض مع رئيس المحكمه الدستوريه الروسيه
خريطه وضعتها فرنسا في القرن السابع عشر
وتظهر الخريطه الاراضي التي كانت جزءا من
الامبراطوريه الروسيه وعدم وجود اوكرانيا
صوره اليوم من اوروغواي التي تعيش حاله
جفاف تاريخيه اثرت على الالاف ما السبب هو
انعدام الامطار ام سوء اداره الامدادات
ونقص الاستثمار لا يهم فالمهم بالنسبه
للالاف من الاسر في اوروغواي الان هو
توفير مياه صالحه للشرب بعد ان بلغت
مستويات المياه في الخزان الرئيسي للبلاد
ادنى مستوى في تاريخها وتقدر شركه المياه
والحكومه المياه المتبقيه في الخزان
بحوالي 10% من سعته
تراه يتجول في شوارع صيدا يساعد السياح
المحليين والاجانب ويحدثهم عن المعالم
التاريخيه للمدينه يحركه حبه لبلاده
ورغبته في مساعده والده المريض انه عبد
الرحمن اصغر مرشد سياحي في لبنان في جعبته
الكثير من تاريخ بلاده والقليل من اللغه
الانجليزيه لكنها كافيه كافيه ليبدا رحلته
مع السياح كل يوم بعد المدرسه لزياره قلاع
صيدا ومناطقها الاثريه اما هدفه فهو
متابعه دراسته ليصبح يوما ما مرشدا محترفا
وفي حالنا توصل
شكرا جزيلا لكم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه
ننتقل الاخبار الساعه مع زميل صهيب شرعي
مساء الخير صهيب مساء الخير راويه كالعاده
اذا جوله سريعه الشامله والمتنوعه اخبار
الساعه في الصداره الحرب الاوكرانيه الوضع
في السودان كذلك هو ازمه سقف الدين
الامريكي
شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات